there's a conversation
with you
with harry about how dark your baby is
going to be
potentially and what that would mean or
look like
it felt for a moment
they're gonna say who said it the couple
did consider the options when it came to
revealing the name of the person that
had made the racist comments about the
color of archie's skin and we don't know
whether it was perhaps a future air to
the throne that made those comments the
queen made it clear it was going to be
discussed privately
but also at the same time you know we
haven't seen the royal family condemn
racism in any way 28 pages of more royal
bombshells are out today in finding
freedom's epilogue including the fact
that oprah had just one weekend to
prepare for their sit-down harry and
megan wanted to speak out months earlier
do you think that they were happy with
the aftermath of that that interview
this was really an exercise in being
able to share their story authentically
for them it was kind of a one-and-done
thing it's why we haven't seen a whole
lot of them since you know we still
haven't seen lilibet for the first time
we have barely seen archie my father and
my brother they are trapped
they don't get to leave
prince philip was in the hospital when
the interview aired perhaps as far as
i'm aware none of the senior royals
really watched that injury in full you
know they were briefed by their staff
now i can't speak for the younger royals
i'm sure they would have been glued to
it just like everyone else in fact
prince william was actually furious at
the couple's decision to share their
story with the world the epilogue said
that there were some members of the
royal family that were happy that megan
didn't come to prince philip's funeral
there was a feeling of relief that she
wasn't able to come because it would
have overshadowed the day another
bombshell two palace staffers have
backed down on their claims that megan
bullied them we've yet to actually hear
what any of this alleged bullying was
and what's the latest on that royal rift
between william and harry williams has
certainly become someone that is really
living his life for the crown
and harry has really sort of bucked that
they'll never see eye to eye
[Music]